why does so many women become Muslim
these days why do they want is that what
you're going to tell me no
no Islam net is raising funds to
establish a Masjid and Community Center
in Norway and they urgently need your
support this donation will be a sar for
you because every person that comes a
step closer to Allah through your
donation you will in be reaping a reward
click the link and donate what you can
why does so many women become Muslim
these days why they want to be oppressed
is that what you're going to tell me no
no why why does so many mus because they
want to be oppressed women in the world
become Muslim these days you tell me I
don't you better ask them why don't you
tell me what you think they they seem to
find it something that attracts them
Islam really yeah okay I don't suggest
for a moment that women who want to
convert to Islam uh should do so for any
other than perfectly good reasons I have
no problem with Islam as a religion or
with Muslims I have a problem so here's
where I have a problem with this guy
here is um the fact that why is there a
connotation or an insinuation of um
oppression with Muslim women coming to
Islam why why didn't he say oh do you
want them to be more happy do you want
them to be liberated why was the word
oppression used that's what I'm curious
about where's that coming from because
he I know remember he said I know what
sh law wants for a woman exactly and
then he follows that message and he
saves himself with the question of oh oh
is that what you which would be upset
really cuz why would he want that as a
Muslim as a Muslim himself why why did
he mention those three things when he
when he said knows about Sharia uh is is
that what he knows about Sharia because
surely that's that's not a comprehensive
but that even what he said is false
because he said um I mean what
interpretation of sharia law suggests
that there should be no feminist in a in
a pol that's run by it anyway like what
does it mean that so for example let's
let's think about it for a second if you
have a polity and you have women inside
that poity whether they be Muslim women
or non-muslim women would they have to
be forcibly exiled for having those
beliefs where does it ever mention that
in the books of F and Juris Prudence so
he doesn't know about Sharia law ex he
says I do know about it but he's he know
he's got a journalist journalism degree
he doesn't know much about Sharia law
and he's made all these assumptions
asked all these uh un uh kind of just
unjust questions frankly uh and he's
coming back and saying actually I'm not
anti-muslim I'm not anti-islam and
perfectly good reasons and all those
kind of things he's backtracking to me I
need to ask him what's the definition of
Oppression because I believe that if you
can reduce woman down to a sexual object
where the only thing they have to offer
is sex because if you think about it um
at the end of the day if I want to go
and relieve myself I go to the toilet
that's what I do I go to the toilet to
relieve myself we all do yeah and if you
look at it the Western system has
sexualized women to such a level it's as
if to their worldview as if they are
walking toilets where men can just Rel
their themselves inside of them like one
night stands using them and chucking
them so much so that they have broken
down the woman woman to such a level
that women do not feel secure in their
self like when we got over Co yeah
people was wearing masks there was a
study done that showed that woman
carried on wearing masks CU they didn't
want to be judged based on their
appearance or where they were in America
in New York there specific clothes that
they wear so they're not harassed on the
streets so when we're talking about
oppression if majority like when I talk
about Western Woman by the way this
includes a Muslim women who are sadly
inflicted by the Western system so the
point is what what you define as
oppression there are women out there who
are walking who are getting boted
planted dying in the process doesn't
it's actually martydom in the process of
beauty so what does oppression mean
there are billions of women around the
world who have been affected so
oppression on who defined what yeah
that's good uh because what what's the
theory of justice that you're using yeah
and that's a problem with P Morgan I
don't think he has a coherent theory of
Justice that's why he finds it he's so
ambivalent when it comes to these
ethical questions because he doesn't he
doesn't know he's always saying it's a
quandry for me and all these kind of
things and he's conflicted and
ambivalent and is undecided uh because
there he doesn't go to the biblical
obviously he's he says he's a
self-proclaimed Catholic uh in Catholic
in Catholicism we know what the for
example Biblical verses say about
homosexuality and we know what the popes
have said throughout the years on
homosexuality as a sin which is thetive
Judaism says position and we know what
Orthodox Judaism says in fact what Ben
Shapiro he himself has come out and said
that he believes biblically that
homosexuality is a sin um so all of
these things having been said he doesn't
have a theory of Justice that's why he
resorts to looking at Winston Churchill
as some kind of profit effectively
whatever this guy says it must be the
case it must be the truth it's as if he
has become the moral standard these
great white Western figures have become
the moral standard you know the Quran
will ask him a question which it does
you know what
is you
know
have they got Associates with God who
have legislated for them in the religion
what Allah has not given them Authority
in other words where is your morality
coming from it's not it's not coming
from the Divine exactly if so it's it's
a man-made morality and why are you then
imposing that upon other cultures and
other people and also I done a reaction
video of how he treated Ben Shapiro when
he came to this question of
homosexuality it was a whole different
tone I don't know if you've seen it yeah
yeah a whole different tone which I've
reacted to but I think that's I think is
an Clos islamophobe I think it's a big I
I gen believe what he said yesterday to
ABD clearly showed that this is what he
thinks about and that's the reason why
bro he cannot call the IDF um a
terrorist
State he cannot bro you know why because
his loyalties are clear where it's wor
it's as simple as that he dehumanizes
look if you despise something if you see
the Sharia or something and oppressing
woman do you think you are in favor no
therefore you are not going to be in
favor look at the Palestinians if the
Palestinians were Christians do you
think you have this Stone you don't even
use the word acts of terrorism of what's
going on 18,000 people massacred bro so
I think that's it I believe he's just an
islamophobe should we continue the video
I think yeah I think the problem is that
his response should have been clear it
should have been decisive I apologize if
my words have taken out of context I
retract them um and you know I I condemn
he's asking everybody else for
condemnation he should condemn his own
words frankly because they've come at a
very inopportune time we were expecting
a clear decisive retraction yeah now for
him to then say Oh there's a context I'm
sorry what's what what's the context of
using a misogynist islamophobic Trope
yeah at a time where the current ruling
party the conservative party um have
just got rid of su braan who has been
cow Towing to the far right far right is
rising here in the UK so to be
championing you know the tropes that
have been put forward by them is
dangerous and it needs to be dealt with
decisively not oh there's a context also
if there's a context you can link
oppression with Muslim women is is that
what you're saying the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said whoever
builds a Masjid for the sake of Allah
subhana tala Allah will build for him a
similar house in Jenna on that day where
Allah subhana T tells us that our books
will be given and every little at a
weight of Good Deed you've done will be
there and imagine you see a mountain and
you're like what a lucky person which
righteous person and Allah says this is
for you for me yes what did I do you
allowed people to pray you built a
Masjid I never had the money to build a
Masid Allah you helped you gave towards
it and Allah gives you the reward of as
if you've built it donate now guys and
do not delay and share the video for
extra
[Music]
Rewards
oh